[Music]
all right tonight before we do our deep
dive into Muller's band of trump hating
hillary clinton loving lackeys we do
have major breaking news from the hills
John Solomon now according to his new
report tonight
a whistleblower told congressman Ron de
Santos that during an FBI
videoconference about former national
security adviser Michael Flynn well the
senior FBI official made an
inappropriate comment about Flynn which
made it seem like there was a personal
motive to investigate him we'll have
more on that story in a few minutes but
first a special council of Robert
Muller's entire investigation we now
know tonight is one giant cesspool it's
full of corruption partisanship and
unbridled bias it is the epitome of the
Washington DC sewer and swamp and
Muller's Stooges literally are doing
everything within their power and then
some to try and remove presidents from
from office and tonight we have new
information about one of Robert Muller's
top attack dogs who has very deep ties
to Barack Obama Hillary Clinton and the
Democratic Party her name we reveal is
jeanne ray now there's a ton of
information pay very close attention
records show she is a huge Democrat and
since 2008 ray has donated nearly ten
thousand dollars to Democrats now that
includes contributions to Hillary
Clinton in 2015-2016 she also dished out
thousands of dollars to Barack Obama in
oh eight and twenty eleven now it's not
surprising because ray is a registered
Democrat in Washington DC did that sound
like a fair impartial investigator for
all of you watching at home I don't
think so and it only gets worse from
there from 2009 to 2011 ray work
directly with former Obama Attorney
General Eric Holder yeah the same Eric
Holder that proudly declared that he is
part of the Donald Trump resistance and
ray served as a deputy assistant
attorney general in the Office of Legal
Counsel at the DOJ where she advised
Holder the Obama White House and other
top Justice Department officials on all
sorts of legal matters and take a look
at this government document ray is
listed as the attorney for former Obama
deputy national security adviser
ben rhoades when he was being
interviewed about the Benghazi terror
attack
so clearly ray has deep ties to top
obama administration officials look at
this press release from our old law firm
Wilmer Hale that's the same law firm
Robert Muller worked at by the way they
mostly only donate to Democrats
it describes Rhea's quote having served
as a legislative fellow in the office of
formers Senator Tom Daschle and as a
counsel in the US Department of
Justice's office of legal policy if you
don't recall Daschle was the Senate
Majority Leader for the Democrats in the
early 2000s guess what there's more
jeanne ray also has done legal work for
the Clinton Foundation in 20 you can't
make this up in 2015 while at Wilmer
Hale ray defended the Clinton Foundation
against the racketeering lawsuit and
raised named appears at the bottom of
the plea agreement remember George
papadopolis the Trump foreign policy
advisor that nobody ever heard of old
Ray's background and resume what does it
prove she is a total and complete
partisan hack Muller had no business
like in a lot of the other people he
selected selecting her to be a part of
his team but he did it anyway which
should tell you all you need to know
about the type of operation Robert
Muller is running next is one of Robert
Muller's top investigators who is known
as the special counsels pit bull and as
a history of all kinds of unethical
highly questionable strong-armed
prosecutorial tactics and of course I'm
talking about Andrew Weissman now before
we get into his past we have breaking
news last night that highlights
Weissman's political bias in an email
released by Judicial Watch yesterday
Weissman told former acting Attorney
General Sally Yates how proud he was of
her this after Yates denied a direct
order from President Trump and refused
to defend what we now know is
constitutional new then the travel ban
back in January here's the actual email
I am so proud I am in awe thank you so
much all my deepest respects well now
that you know about Weissman well let's
dive into his past our friend colleague
Fox News legal analyst gregg jarrett
he's been going over this guy's record
with a fine-tooth comb
guess what Weissman
is a legal nightmare now we have to know
Weissman has deep and close ties to both
Muller and the disgraced former FBI
director James Comey he's worked closely
with both of them for years and he has
donated over $4,000 to Democrats like
Barack Obama so there's no way he'd have
any political bias on sure right well
this is the part that's still deeply
disturbing when Weissman was the top
prosecutor remember the Enron task force
well he secured a highly controversial
obstruction of justice case against
American accounting giant Arthur
Andersen it destroyed that company it
put tens of thousands of people out of
work it drove that company out of
business and in 2005 the US Supreme
Court overturned Weissman's conviction
in an almost unprecedented 9-0 unanimous
ruling they excoriated him for his
behavior and that's not the only example
of Weissman's hard-charging overly
aggressive tactics as part of the Enron
investigation Weitzman sent for Merrill
Lynch executives to jail for as long as
a year guess what they were innocent
that conviction was also later
overturned this time by the fifth US
Circuit Court of Appeals here's the
bottom line
Weissman guess what he's a legal tyrant
he has been accused of doing just about
anything to secure a conviction does he
not care about equal justice under the
law he's been accused of intimidating
witnesses making up crimes that do not
even exist and even withholding evidence
that would have been exculpate or II and
helped the defense of one case and
Weissman is also directly tied to that
corrupt uranium one deal and Obama
administration's attempt to hide it from
you the American people Weissman
guess what he was in charge of the do
J's fraud section during the Russian
bribery scheme and Gregg Jarrett pointed
out that Weissman signature looked there
it's at the bottom of the plea deal that
was signed by the Russian businessman at
the center of that case now also tonight
breaking information about the Trump
aiding Hillary loving FBI agent Peter
struck he's the guy that was fired from
Muller's team for political bias towards
President Trump another one of the dream
team of robert muller now the DOJ is
reviewing ten
thousand text messages that struck said
to his FBI official girlfriend Lisa page
she also worked for Muller and what for
to determine which specific messages
that we're struck was attacking
president Trump they need to be turned
over to the House Intelligence Committee
so at this hour it's unclear how many of
the ten thousand messages have to do
with President Trump or Mohs
investigation it should be an
interesting read
now the DOJ says this could take weeks
or even months
can we move a little faster it's not
that hard we're also learning tonight
that structs dirty and bias fingerprints
guess what they're all over the fake
news anti Trump Russian propaganda
dossier bought and paid for by Hillary
and the DNC that she was running and
according to a report struck and his
team they were tasked with handling the
dossier when it was given to the FBI and
according to other reports information
that that fake news dossier was used to
get a FISA warrant to surveil the Trump
campaign advisor quarter page stop and
think about this Hillary Clinton bought
and paid for Russian propaganda to
influence an election sound familiar
and they might have used it to get a
warrant to investigate an opposition
party a campaign a a president-elect
this is insanity struck is as biased as
they come and here are more reasons why
according to a report it was struck who
signed the document that officially
started the Russian collusion witch-hunt
now the Trump hating FBI agent also
oversaw the FBI interviews get this a
former national security adviser
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn and as
we told you about last night
structs mistress lisa page served on
robert Muller's dream team before
leaving now here's where it gets really
disturbing as her own catherine herridge
is reporting well-struck played a
pivotal role also in the clinton email
server investigation you know the one
where they actually had an exoneration
letter before the investigation and he
even took part in the 2016 interview of
Hillary Clinton herself by the way she
was never put under oath and we're also
learning that struck participated in the
FBI interviews of key Clinton aides and
allies Huma Abedin Cheryl Mills and we
showed you last night how lies
we're told by both of them and here's
the most egregious example of Struck's
rampant political bias he's responsible
for changing that crucial language in
James Comey statement that exonerated
Hilary before they investigated he's the
one that revised grossly negligent -
extremely careless which gave them an
excuse to let Hillary walk now all of
this is shocking it's incomprehensible
it's a smoking gun proof that Moniz
probe is a total political sham it's a
witch-hunt it needs to be shut down
immediately if we believe in the rule of
law and our Constitution but guess what
the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein who appointed Muller as the
special counsel he's saying tonight he's
satisfied with this investigation
mr. Rosenstein are you serious you need
to wake the hell up get your head out of
the stand and take a look at what is
actually going on this is about law and
order and legal justice under the law
apparently Rosenstein is the only person
apparently in America that doesn't seem
to realize I guess unless you work at
fake news CNN or conspiracy TV MSNBC you
seem to be the only one that doesn't
realize there are very serious flaws
with Muller's investigation this is
exactly why we have been saying it's
time for Rosenstein to pack his boxes
leave the Department of Justice because
this is an injustice
Muller's investigation is troubling
Democrats are using it to attack a duly
elected president the one you elected
and here's an example earlier today you
have 58 geniuses in the House of
Representatives all Democrats supporting
a resolution to impeach President Trump
for what the bias the politics whirling
around mowers an investigation is beyond
alarming at this point it's been a year
of this but it's still part of a much
larger attack and it's all aimed at the
President of the United States and of
course it's being orchestrated by deep
state operatives and Obama holdovers now
we have seen example after example of
former Obama administration officials
going after attempting to discredit the
president every day day in day out look
at James clapper the former Director of
National Intelligence now works
big news CNN he's repeatedly attacked
President Trump here's one small example
are you questioning his fitness yes I do
IIIi really questioned his ability to
his fitness to be in this office and I
also I'm beginning to wonder about his
motivation for it maybe maybe he is
looking for a way out how much longer
does the country have to to borrow a
phrase endure this nightmare pretty
disgraceful and former Obama CIA
director John Brennan more deep state
well he's made this shocking admission
when testifying before Congress watch
him I want to make sure that every
information and bit of it tells us that
we had was shared with the bureau so
that they could take it it was well
beyond my mandate as director of CIA to
follow on any of those leads that
involved u.s. persons but I made sure
that anything that was involving u.s.
persons including anything involving the
individuals involved in the Trump
campaign was shared with the bureau
so what Brennan did was do everything
within his power to make sure that the
FBI and the deep State were going after
Trump and his campaign now after hearing
statements like that should we really be
at all surprised that at the beginning
of the Trump administration remember we
had 125 deep state leaks and 126 days
imagine this when does it ever happen
that a conversation with a sitting
president and a prime minister or
president of another country was ever
leaked I can't think of a time and we
can't forget that right before he left
off as President Obama remember we
talked about this
he signed executive order one two triple
three which made it easier to share
intelligence so everybody across the
government agencies had access why did
he do it why didn't he do it during his
term now there's also widespread
unmasking of American citizens including
Trump associates and at one point during
the end of the Obama administration
former UN Ambassador member Samantha
power why would she be unmasking people
caught up incidentally in surveillance
at the rate of one American at
day and then we have Ben Rhodes former
Obama deputy national security adviser
remember talking about the attorney ray
now remember him he was a person of
interest in the unmasking scandal so
what appears what the Obama
administration was in fact deliberate by
unleashing this deep state power to
strike against the incoming president
before he even took office and take a
look at how former Ambassador John
Bolton tonight is describing this mess
that is going on in this country tonight
as a Wall Street Journal this is the
first attempted coup d'etat in American
history I mean it's a mini coup d'etat
but it's it goes right along with the
idea that they should have won elections
where power is not minor
you have to listen this is not a game
what is happening in this country is
dangerous and it needs to be stopped
before the deep state can overthrow the
president that you the American people
voted for a duly elected president we'll
have more on that in a minute but first
also tonight we have scandals continuing
to ago engulf the Democratic Party all
across the spectrum senator Al Franken
senator groper
the one-time darling of the left while
he's in deep political turmoil tonight
two more women are now accusing that
senator of misconduct including a former
congressional aide who alleges that
Franken tried to forcibly kiss her in
2006 after taping a radio show now
according to her accounts he were buffed
the kiss and Franken allegedly responded
by telling her quote well it's my right
as an entertainer and Franken has
categorically denied that allegation now
the second new claim of misconduct comes
from a woman who says the Franken groped
her at an election party in 2008 she
described what happened writing quote I
don't let my husband touch me like that
in public and today dozens of Democratic
senators said it's time for Franken to
resign Franken apparently will make a
statement tomorrow and there were
reports earlier tonight that he would
step down but Franklin's office is
disputing that claim and they're now
saying no final decision has been made
and that Franken is consulting with his
family and just yesterday Democratic
congressman john conyers he announced he
would not seek reelection he retired
after his own sexual misconduct
handles by the way for the record in
terms of being fair and mounds I never
called for Conyers to resign as I have
said many times everyone deserves due
process even somebody that I have deep
political disagreements with he denied
the charges in his case
senator Franken different story he's
admitted groper and there's photographic
evidence of that misconduct we've all
seen that picture I've known Leanne
tweetIn for years Franken groping radio
talk show host Leanne Tweed anon a USO
tour and by the way only now are we
seeing after the eighth person has come
forward a flood of Democratic senators
calling on Franken to resign so don't be
fooled by any of this this Democratic
decision today obviously was coordinated
and to turn on Franken it's it's purely
political if they were really all these
Democrats the great champions of women
rights that they claim why didn't they
call for Franklin's resignation after
the picture and why did they wait until
eight women had to come forward with
similar claims and he admitted a lot of
it and after decades of defending sexual
predators Oh Bill Clinton for 30 years
the Democrats were to believe now
finally are are actually credible on
this issue or they really paying a
political price and playing a political
game is this not about political
expediency and not principled in play
now